today we're sharing our drunk horror
stories one summer I was living in Japan
for a couple months one weekend we went
to the party district in Tokyo called
Roppongi there was a great deal at the
bar that we went to where it's like pay
a thousand yen which comes out to like
under $9 and you get to drink all you
want to drink so we did that and calm
the lines and dude we ended up trying to
make the train back because it was like
the last train that was leaving Tokyo to
head back home drunkenly we're like
three of us are like running trying to
catch the train and I'm like I can't
find my MetroCard I'm just crying and
just like in a fit of like rage all of a
sudden my friends are like what are we
gonna do and they look around at me and
I'm just like hey guys
and it's like my MetroCard and they were
just like the train left already and so
we ended up staying the entire night out
on the streets of Tokyo I proceeded to
just sleepwalk in and out of sleep
because I was pretty drunk
we hung out by a dumpster and we're
singing camp songs and hung out at a
McDonald's at one point we're eating
burgers at one point this guy ran and
tonight he like turned back and wanted a
fight and I just was like yeah and then
I pretty much just came to as we're
walking the streets at like maybe like 5
a.m. we all ended up taking the train
ride back home at like 5:30 if I could
talk to myself back then and I would
probably tell myself to pace myself so
my drunk horror story is when I was a
senior in college halfway through the
semester my boyfriend of almost two
years broke up with me so I went to this
party in a basement as one does it was
like some DJ set and I remember getting
there and I was already drunk I brought
a big purse and in my purse I had a
six-pack of tallboy Narragansetts
in my bag which are like cheap like New
England beer oh but yeah anyway I was
drinking and I was like dancing and I
was like talking to all these people
basically I guess I came to when we were
leaving the party I like puke all over
the kitchen on this party and then we
got in a cab and I went home and my
friend just let me stay at her place the
only things that I remember are
basically these pictures that I have on
my phone one of my friends took my phone
and then she was taking pictures I just
looked drunk like I have never looked so
drunk in my entire life my hair was like
up but it was like falling out my makeup
was like all over my face I was happy
but it was awful and then I woke up and
I felt really guilty and awful and it
was one of the worst hangovers of my
life basically here's the thing kids
drink responsibly every time and don't
drink six tall boys maybe max - my first
time I got drunk it's probably the
horror story so one of my co-workers was
having a birthday party so I lived in
the North Bronx and she lived all the
way in Far Rockaway in Brooklyn now
that's like two separate sides of the
earth first I went to my friend and
Harlem's house and we got that juice now
thought juice is another term for wine
coolers or that's what we used to call
it back in my day and we drank some of
those and then we went to Far Rockaway
and that's when everything started to
get blurry so we get there and I
immediately started drinking it I had no
idea what I was drinking so then
everyone's dancing on the dance floor I
already don't know how to dance I'm all
up against the wall falling down and
everyone is laughing at me
I guess my friends think I'm a little
bit out of control and we need to leave
and I thought maybe we need to leave too
because I had work at 5:30 and
exploiting we're leaving all I remember
was I was cursing out guys dudes in
Brooklyn and it's just me and two girls
then we get to the train station I can't
even go up stairs I'm throwing up all
over myself when we're trying to go up
the stairs then we're on the train I
woke sit down I keep yelling at
strangers and we had to transfer
because my friends were afraid so we get
to my friend's house in Harlem at this
point I'm pretty sure it's gotta be like
5:00 5:30 a.m. and she calls in sick for
me at work tells the manager I'm sick I
can hear the manager yelling at her
through the phone the next thing I
remember is waking up and I felt
something I felt something in my kids I
had to give myself what I did was I took
those pants basically used it as a towel
to clean myself up and then I put on my
work pants and decided to go to work
even though I had already called in sick
I'm about to clock in my manager is
cursing me out everybody I basically
just went through the motions of walking
right out of work hopped on the train so
I go home and then I get a text message
asking me to come into work to do a
closing [ __ ] all right if I was talking
to the aja who got that drunk I would
say listen I really need you to care
more about your safety
[Music]